juste rappeler aussi que la peut-être la
modération du temps du discours
aujourd'hui de jean guy talamoni elle
est aussi directement liée à un rapport
de force qui existe avec gilles simeoni
alors qu'après 2015 on a bien vu que la
ligne talamoni elle est minoritaire ils
ont fait à peu près 7% et que celui qui
ramasse les voies celui qui parle a
finalement au plus grand nombre de
corses et donc susceptibles de remporter
les élections comme ils l'ont fait hier
c'est bien la ligne
simeoni donc il faut aussi voir
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un enjeu finalement
qui est devant eux c'est là il ya c'est
fini les deux les deux ans de campagne
pour cette élection là maintenant il va
falloir être capable de 2,2 de fibres de
gérer d'appliquer un programme de parler
au plus grand nombre et d'être pris
aussi pour finalement un gestionnaire
crédible et légitime et pas simplement
légitime si vous voulez par les ondes